[Música]
las grietas están abiertas los diputados
argentinos rechazaron el ataque contra
cristina fernández durante una sesión
especial donde el texto final fue
aprobado por amplia mayoría
la honorable cámara de diputados de la
nación expresa su enérgico repudio al
intento de magnicidio contra la
vicepresidenta y dos veces presidenta de
la nación doctora cristina fernández de
kirchner cristina está viva pero podría
no estarlo la coalición gobernante
frente de todos propuso un texto donde
denunció que el ataque fue motivado por
los discursos de odio y las divisiones
se hicieron notar hay un punto de la
situación que vivimos que me parecen muy
importantes los tan trillados discursos
de odio existen los vemos en muchos
lugares los vemos repetidos los vemos
retransmitidos hay personas que son
habladas por ese odio aquellos que
hablan
discurso del odio no tienen la menor
idea lo que es un discurso del odio lean
la comisión americana de derechos
humanos artículo 3 inciso 5 lo que es el
discurso del odio al acá lo que hay
discrepancias políticas ideológicas
los diputados de propuesta republicana
partido del expresidente mauricio macri
abandonaron el hemiciclo y la izquierda
se abstuvo de votar javier mi ley líder
del partido de extrema derecha la
libertad avanza rompió el silencio que
mantenía tras el atentado no es otro
desde la libertad avanza dejamos claro
nuestro repudio a la violencia pero no
aceptado de ninguna manera este circo
dantesco de la política muchas gracias
señora presidente
la defensa de fernández adelantó que
pedirá que la causa sea calificada como
un intento de femicidio mientras el
acusado se negó a declarar frente a las
autoridades